تنعطف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا يتغير شكل
القتال لتاخذ القوات الاوكرانيه خطوات نحو
الامان تقصف قاعده للقاذفات الروسيه بعيده
المدى والقديره على حمل رؤوس النوويه على
بعد اكثر من 700 كلم في العمق عن الحدود
تضرب القوات الاوكرانيه ليست المره الاولى
لكن تصريحا من القوات الاوكرانيه يرفع
التوتر بين الجانبين يقول المتحدث
الاوكراني ان الروس مخطئون اذا اعتقدوا ان
الحرب لن تمسهم في العمق ليس هذا وحسب من
جانب واحد هذه المره يعلن الروس عن قتل من
وصفوا بمجموعه من المخربين الذين حاولوا
التسلل الى مقاطعه بريانس الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا لم يعلق له الاوكرانيون لكن
الحدث ان صح التفاصيله فقد يعني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قررت بالفعل نقل المعركه الى
العمق الروسي كما اشار المتحدث باسم
القوات الاخرانيه سابقه تبدو هذه الانباء
الابرز تطورات الميدانيه للحرب لكن
الميدان داخل الحدود الاوكرانيه لم يهدا
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه ان نظيرتها
الروسيه نفذت خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر
من 40 هجوما في المقابل تعرض وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعملا قتاليه باستخدام نظام دفاع
جوي الروسي متخصص في اسقاط المسيرات
بعد 10 اشهر من القتال ثمه حديث ليس جديدا
عن طاوله المفاوضات يقول وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه ان الغربه سيضطر في نهايه المطاف
الى التفاوض مع روسيا
لن نركض خلفهم فقد قطعوا تقريبا كل
العلاقات
تصريحاته لافروف وين كانت لنظره حاده
فانها بوضوح الى التفاوض لذلك امر لفت
النظر اليها الرئيس الروسي عندما قال ان
كل النزاعات تنتهي بالتفاوض متهما
اوكرانيا والغرب برفض الدخول في هذا
المسار الاخرانيون يتحدثون بلغه اخرى تقول
الرئاسه هناك ان للحرب نهايه واحده هي
هزيمه المعتدي ومعاقبته بقسوه
لم يمنعنا من الحق المزيد من الهزائم
بالغزاه ومع ذلك يجب ان نكون جاهزين لاي
سيناريو
السيناريوه مفتوحه اذا قد تكون من بينها
نهايه هذه الحرب بالجلوس الى طاوله واحده
او استمرار القتال اكثر واكثر اي من قليله
قبل بدايه عام جديد واسابيع قليله كذلك
قبل ان تطوي هذه الحرب عامها الاول